[Music]
santa claus receives millions of letters
from kids all around the world every
year and when they are old enough to
write it on their own but not mature
enough to know how it really works we
end up with hilarious results even
though we can't really know if any of
them are fake we want to believe in
magic this time make sure you watch this
video until the end to see what a little
girl asks santa to do to prove that he
exists if you love christmas as much as
we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 20 most
hilarious kids christmas wishes that
made even santa laugh the millennial we
know that most kids these days want a
smartphone for christmas even if they
already have one it won't be good two
years after and they will have to ask
santa for a new one this kid might not
be old enough to ask for an iphone x but
he knows exactly how it became an
essential part of our everyday life this
is why he told santa that he should text
his father to know what he wants for
christmas what is funny about this is
that he actually used a letter to write
that this is what happens when you live
in a world where everyone but you has a
phone the questions this girl didn't ask
for any iphone or the new video game
console this year the only thing she
wanted was for santa to answer a couple
of questions what are your favorite
cookies and what are your least favorite
cookies do you have a beard all the year
how much do you weigh how many elves do
you have she certainly wasn't shy
because she also asked him if his poop
was the color of holiday candies and how
many pairs of underwear does he have we
don't know if she ever got an answer to
all these questions but one thing is
sure this letter made santa claus smile
and this is the best gift he could ever
receive for christmas the batteries it
happened to all of us before we received
a really amazing gift for christmas but
then we can't even use it because we
have no batteries all the stores are
closed and we have to wait for the next
morning to buy some batteries while all
our siblings are having fun with their
gifts this is why this kid had a really
brilliant idea he told santa that if he
brings presents that require batteries
he should bring the batteries to we hope
that he will get the message and that he
won't make the same mistake ever again
we can't believe that he just learned
that after more than 100 years in the
business the pony it is not the first
time that we see a kid who wants a pony
for christmas after all it would be
every kid's dream to go to school on the
back of this tiny horse but when you
want such an impressive gift you should
at least ask politely this girl didn't
get the memo because she told santa that
he'd better bring her a pony this year
or there will be consequences she even
drew an angry pony to intimidate him we
should tell her that only the nicest
girls in the world get a pony and
threatening santa will only get her coal
the dragon even though it is rare to see
a kid receiving a pony for christmas it
is possible but when a kid asks for a
magical creature it is kind of hard to
explain that it doesn't exist even
though santa is real this kid took it to
a whole new level when he didn't only
ask for a dragon he asked santa if he
could become one and if it is not
possible he would at least like to be
turned into a pet dragon we should tell
him that only young boys and young girls
get a gift for christmas if he
transforms into a dragon he won't be
able to ask santa to change him back
into a little kid be careful what you
wish for the brother in december you
want to be as nice as you can to make
sure you don't end up on the naughty
list this is probably why this young
girl decided to help her younger brother
write his letter to santa but she
clearly didn't have the best intentions
claire told santa about the gifts that
she wants and she even said that her
brother mitch wants a skateboard but he
shouldn't have one after all he might be
very kind hearted but he also has a bad
temper and he also writes messy and
doesn't like to read at least we can say
that claire is very honest and she
deserves a gift for that the actor this
girl is just like any of us she wanted
santa to bring her favorite actor to her
house and she chose leonardo dicaprio
simply because she thinks that he is
really cute she would like to meet him
but she wrote this word like the meat
that comes from animals so we're afraid
that she might want to do some terrible
things to him if this was really
possible we think that celebrities would
spend way too much time traveling around
the world during the holidays but wait
she didn't even ask for a gift for
christmas it's the summer vacations
better luck next time girl the alarm
this kid knew that santa was coming to
his home on christmas eve but he thought
about one problem how is he going to
enter the house without being noticed if
there is an alarm this is why the kid
warned santa that he should leave before
6am because his alarm goes off at 6am we
don't know about you but we would have
taken advantage of the situation if we
were him if he didn't tell santa he
could have heard the alarm go off during
the night and wake up to meet him but at
the same time we think that if he did
that he would have ended up on the
naughty list the weapons this kid wished
for one of the greatest things in the
world he wanted peace in the world santa
usually answers that this is really hard
to do but this kid was going to tell him
how to do it on christmas when he was in
everyone's house he could take all the
guns and put them in his sack and hide
them at the north pole and then no one
could kill anyone anymore in the world
we think that this is one of the
greatest ideas ever so we hope that you
are going to work on this santa the
meeting we have to admit that we all
wondered if santa claus was real or not
now that we are grown-ups we know that
he exists who else would put gifts under
the christmas tree but we understand why
kids had a doubt after all santa is so
popular that he doesn't have time to
meet all the kids in the world and this
one wanted to make sure that the man he
admires really did exist and this is why
he had one special request he really
wanted to see santa and it was even the
second time he asked this come on bring
this kid to the mall and let him meet
santa claus
the fashionista some kids know exactly
what they want and kailyn is not an
exception we know that she will grow up
to be a true fashionista not only did
she write her letter on a pink paper
with hello kitty but she also made it
obvious that she loves shopping and
being pretty kailyn asked for 100 a 50
gift card to some store she likes and a
note signed by her parents saying that
she is allowed to paint her nails she
even added on the back of the letter
that the 50 gift card can't be to any
pool places and it has to already have
money on it we better give kailyn what
she wants because we don't know what she
is going to do
the money so we know that caleb wanted
santa claus to give her a lot of things
but it was still reasonable however
chris had much more ambition when he
wrote a letter to santa claus he asked
for 5.3 billion dollars and another
letter from santa this is totally
unreasonable santa doesn't have time to
write another letter the amount of money
is also surprisingly really specific the
funniest thing about this is that chris
said that he is sorry for what he did in
the past which means that he hasn't
always been a good boy if only he had
been really nice maybe he would have had
a chance
the test this kid wrote a letter to
santa claus last year and he was really
disappointed to see that he didn't get
the video game console he wanted if only
santa had told him before he wouldn't
have so many expectations this is why
this time he asked santa if he was going
to get another champ and to make sure
that he answers he asked him to circle
yes or no but this answer wasn't enough
to satisfy this kid he also asked santa
to explain his decision and gave him a
couple of lines to write we think that
it would be funnier to see the answer
but unfortunately it looks like santa
has nothing to say the catalog one of
the things that we love the most when
christmas is coming is that we have the
opportunity to look at the walmart
catalog we circle everything we love and
then give it to our mom so she can buy
all the things we like and this girl
decided to do the same thing with santa
too tammy cut all the beautiful jewelry
that she wanted so santa would know
exactly what she wants the rings are a
little bit expensive but we think that
the other pieces of jewelry are totally
reasonable by making things clear tammy
is sure that she'll get what she wants
for christmas the cookies we think that
we are making a pretty good deal we
receive free gifts for christmas and the
only thing that santa wants in exchange
is some delicious cookies isaiah didn't
only think about him but also about the
reindeers when he decided to give them
some carrots too unfortunately not
everyone will get cookies this year
that's because isaiah's mom probably
doesn't want him to eat too much sugar
because he gets too excited this is why
the kid wrote that he wishes he was
eating the cookies too but once he
receives the gifts from santa we think
that he won't be thinking about this
anymore the diet here's another story
about cookies and this time santa will
be disappointed too that's because
lexi's mom is on a diet this is why the
young girl had to tell santa that they
don't have cookies anymore but at least
you can eat some cheeses instead they're
good too this young girl really cares
about her family because she doesn't
only support her mother who is on a diet
she also thinks about her pets she made
sure that shanna won't forget about
molly who has been a very good kitten
and little bit who is a good puppy too
we think that we should give some
candies to this girl for christmas she
deserves it the boat we know that santa
usually travels on a magical sleigh
flying in the sky thanks to his
reindeers but this kid thought that the
king of the north could help him with
another kind of vehicle jordan wished
for his boat to work as right now he
just has an operational boat sitting in
his yard he even drew the boat to make
sure that santa knew what he was talking
about and we think that we have the
perfect solution for him santa should
give him a dolphin with a red nose to
pull the boat this way jordan could give
gifts to kids in warmer countries when
he grows up the leggings why would you
ask for anything else for christmas when
you already have all you need to be
happy at home most of us don't care
about what we have until we lose it and
only then we realize how much we loved
it this is exactly what happened to
sophie she lost her favorite pair of
leggings and couldn't find them anywhere
this is why she wrote a letter to santa
so he could tell her where they were we
think that santa didn't find them so he
will have to give her new ones for
christmas but the greatest gift sophie
will ever receive is learning that you
should appreciate the things that you
have because you never know when you are
going to lose them
the dad sometimes parents are jealous of
the gifts that we receive and the
attention that santa claus gets this is
why they tell us that santa is not real
and they're actually the ones who buy
the gift this kid had a little doubt
when he started writing this letter and
santa took it a little personally until
he said that he thinks he's real however
he won't need to give him presents this
year because his dad is going to give
him some presents he even added that he
doesn't think it's nice to say that
santa is big jolly and fat even though
he is jolly we think that this dad had a
bad idea and he will actually have to
buy some presents instead of waiting for
santa to bring them
the proof some other parents told this
young boy that santa doesn't exist but
adam wanted to give him one last chance
he said that he is not saying that he
doesn't believe in him but he would like
him to sign this paper to show that he
really exists just to make sure and
santa really did sign this paper with ho
ho
we told you he was real if you could ask
santa to give you one thing anything
what would it be don't be shy to answer
in the comment section down below we
love to hear what you think that's it
for 20 most hilarious kids christmas
wishes that made even santa laugh for
more stories like this make sure you
watch 20 snapchat captions that made art
fun again thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]